hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about
a subject that comes up from time to
time it's kind of two subjects in one
i often get asked um
can we learn more than one language at
the same time
and another question is you know
how difficult is it to learn related or
similar languages well first of all i'm
going to follow this video with a video
where i speak in both ukrainian and
russian with subtitles i had someone
uh familiar with both languages provide
us with subtitles so i'm putting those
up
and you can hear the differences between
ukrainian
and russian
um
obviously if you study a language that's
similar to a language that you already
know you have a tremendous advantage
because chances are the vocabulary is
going to be similar
the grammar is going to be similar
similar
and obviously
as i've said many times the more similar
a new language is to a language you
already know the easier it is so i'm
struggling with arabic right now where
there are
practically no
cognates there are no words that i
recognize from other languages maybe
when i go to study farsi i'll see some
arabic
words in the farsi and that might help
me so the more similar they are the
better
but there are some traps
okay first of all you can't assume that
you just kind of tweak your
spanish and you'll have portuguese uh
when i first went at portuguese i tried
that i bought a book on the differences
between
spanish and portuguese in terms of
vocabulary and stuff like that
and it really didn't help me that much
because those you know those obvious
differences where they say you know this
in spanish and that in portuguese that's
a small percentage of the vocabulary you
actually have to get used to using all
of the language and understanding all of
the language so just zooming at least
this was my experience just trying to
shortcut the process by just picking out
those few words that are different and
then pretending you're speaking in this
other language i find i found that it
didn't work
i spent some time on some portuguese
phrases in this living language course
that i bought and i listened a lot
jogging around and listening and went to
portugal and i people just switched to
english so i couldn't really communicate
i didn't know what they were saying
so the second time i went at it much
more thoroughly thoroughly linked style
lots of listening and reading immersing
myself into the language
sort of projecting myself as a speaker
of portuguese and then i was able to do
much better and it really didn't matter
whether to me whether i was listening to
brazilian portuguese or portuguese
portuguese i was putting myself into
another language environment
and we have many members here at linc
who are portuguese probably more brazil
not portuguese brazilian probably we
have more portuguese speakers than
spanish speakers i don't know for sure
but they of course want to learn spanish
and sometimes i get questions about that
and i always say you know the big thing
is don't kind of hang back
in the comfort of your portuguese
pronunciation the same is true in
reverse of course
try to project yourself as an
argentinian or a colombian or a spaniard
or something try to really project
yourself into that environment so the
same with the slavic languages the first
language i learned was was russian
obviously i spent a lot of time with
russian then i did czech
and then i came to
ukrainian and even polish and by the way
this morning i had a one-hour chat with
a polish tutor from italki in polish we
spoke in polish now
i am sure that a significant percentage
of the words i used were either
ukrainian or czech or russian but we
were communicating that's another
advantage when you are in closely
related languages if the goal is
communication in a way it doesn't matter
if you're mixing spanish with portuguese
or italian or
polish with ukrainian or russian
people are going to understand you so if
the main goal is to communicate
and of course you understand them
because you studied those languages so
your comprehension is
usually a lot better than your ability
to deliver the language but you're still
able to communicate
but the funny thing is again i'm kind of
rambling a bit here but the funny thing
is that i felt in my polish conversation
that while i probably made more mistakes
than the last time i spoke polish
the overall experience was easier
because i had in the intervening period
had studied ukrainian so that my
comfort level with slavic languages
in total
was
higher so i felt quite comfortable
and i would throw out a word and you
know if it's if it's uh peras and polish
and zara's and ukrainian or vice versa i
can't remember half the time it didn't
matter because we were communicating and
i felt comfortable and so feeling
comfortable
and confident is extremely important in
learning any language
but
i guess where i want to come to in all
this is there has to be a desire to
learn that other language there has to
be a desire to become one of them and
very often you see people speakers of
similar languages and particularly
native speakers who don't force
themselves
and i was i listened to a lot of
portuguese podcasts
and i would hear portuguese people speak
spanish and they would try to speak
spanish like spaniards and they sounded
spanish and very often i would hear
spanish people
who would
probably
change a few words hablar became falar
and desert instead of defer and that was
about it but for the rest of time they
were just speaking spanish so and and
i've noticed for example mandarin
speakers who come who move to vancouver
let's say
young people young kids who want to
connect with cantonese speakers here in
vancouver they learn
in no time because actually if the
language is that close you can learn
but older people they simply don't want
to let go of their mandarin of the
pronunciation of the comfort and so they
will just speak
mandarin or spanish or russian
uh so that typically it's the more
dominant language group that is
unwilling to project itself into that
call it less widely spoken language
group so
i guess to summarize it's a tremendous
advantage to learn
related languages
easy to confuse them but it doesn't
matter because you're still
communicating in my view
but you should force yourself to make a
special effort to get out of the comfort
zone of the dom of the language that
where you are stronger
in order to really
penetrate immerse yourself get into
sound natural in
the
next language within that language group
and it is fun
uh you know i've done you know they're
not the same language family but chinese
helped me with japanese helped me with
korean obviously the slavic languages i
was able to go from one to the next to
the next
if i ever wanted to learn
uh danish or norwegian it would be a
piece of cake but if i did it i would go
for the danish pronunciation i wouldn't
try to say a few danish words with a
swedish accent i would totally go for it
and the same of course is true for
romance languages and that's why for
example romanian i was able to learn
fairly quick quickly
but i left my italian behind me i became
romanian so there it is a bit of a
ramble on learning uh related languages
and now you can hear me
in ukrainian and uh
russian neither of which i spent a lot
of time at over the last year or two but
you'll certainly get the sense that my
russian is stronger than my ukrainian
and my russian creeps into my ukrainian
okay thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you